hey guys how's it goin welcome DJ likes
mij short for iJustine you just call me
just seen as cool we're friends here so
you guys may notice I got a little
something going on with the hair I like
to call this look the look this came
about because I was playing The Sims 3
and I made a sim that looked like me oh
look at that
that's real freaking cute get out of
here in the comments guys we're like
Justin you never wear your hair like
that that's not accurate well yes it is
moving right along to videos that I like
this week kind of a slow week until
Justin Bieber went and freaked out on to
paparazzi and what I like about this
video was Justin was actually standing
up for himself nobody wants to be
harassed and abused by press or somebody
calling you names granted Justin
probably should have just got in the van
and not said a thing can we just please
leave Justin Bieber alone like he is a
nice sweet soul and I love him so leave
him alone
who's next video I hardly ever really
sit through entire videos I'm always
skipping around but this video I
actually did make it the entire way
through when I was captivated by the guy
interviewing Mila Kunis he said he was
so nervous I'm petrified
they never interviewed anybody before
I've never done this before so and she
made him feel so comfortable or not so
comfortable they asked her out I think
like five times my mate Tico is he's
getting married soon oh good he did so
again like a plus-one to his wedding
asked me to go with you to this wedding
I'm just wondering so last week I was
super excited about tomb raider that I
forgot about Sim City that was coming
out this week and if you want the people
that got Sim City as well then this is
probably a very similar scenario that
you've been having this past week but
you know what isn't it Mario Luigi I
mean Mario's over there your friend
Mario's over there he wants to play Sim
City doesn't hate someone else that we
to me saying that Amazon removed Sim
City from their store because of all the
errors that they were having which I
think it's kind of stupid because let me
tell you what people are still gonna buy
this game they're still gonna complain
about it even if the game worked
perfectly fine people were gonna
complain about something anyway cuz
that's just what everybody likes to do
okay what was I even talking about
started text message incan for god I was
shooting a video you idiot
so we're
call this section style thanks to TIA
JLB for the suggestion simple but
fitting so this week like most weeks I
am obsessed with camo I think many of
you guys be following me on Instagram or
Twitter you know that one of my favorite
things is camo I mean I even have a PC
that is a custom purple camo color I
mean really so this is probably one of
my favorite things to do with camo is
pair it with a really bright color make
yourself seem not so invisible anyway
here is some of my camo collection is
going on with his hair
thank you guys for watching this episode
of IJ likes if you guys have a
suggestion for next week just leave it
in the comments below or send me a tweet
at I just een and use the hashtag IJ
likes and I will see you guys later
don't forget to like this video by
clicking the thumbs up like button and
subscribing so you'll see all the videos
that I will be posting this upcoming
week okay
that's it - I guess all I got for you
I'm gonna go play SimCity see you later
mom
flowers and hold my hand Oh Bruno Mars I
love you Oh take this mic off now